[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis très heureux de
retrouver pour ce s'effrite hebdo c'est
parti pour le sommaire politique
othman noces coup s'est déclaré candidat
aux municipales de 2020 à trappes
il a annoncé son entrée en campagne
jeudi dernier tous les détails dans ce
magazine intempéries in le département a
fait face à de violents orages cette
semaine inondations arbres couchés parmi
les principaux sites touchés l'arboretum
de versailles chèvreloup situé à deux
pas du château de versailles
plus d'informations à suivre enfin dans
le reste de l'actualité l'équipe de
france féminine à préparer sa coupe du
monde dans les yvelines cette semaine
les joueurs se sont entraînés entre le
centre de clairefontaine et croissy sur
seine en football masculin coup de
projecteur sur l'arrivée de laurent
fournier alès poissy l'actualité de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 68
[Musique]
mais d'abord la crise qui se confirme au
sein du parti les républicains après le
mauvais score historique aux dernières
européennes et la démission de laurent
wauquiez
dimanche dernier c'est valérie pécresse
qui claquent la porte l'ancien député
des yvelines qui avait annoncé son
mouvement libre en 2017 souhaite
l'émergence d'une troisième voie entre
la république en marche et le
rassemblement national la présidente de
la région ile de france estime que la
reconstruction de la droite ne peut se
faire au sein du parti aléas républicain
on continue à parler politique les
élections européennes passées le scrutin
des municipales programmé en 2020 est
désormais dans toutes les têtes
attrape déjà trois candidatures
officiellement déclaré dernière en date
celle du conseiller municipal
d'opposition othman nassr où il a réussi
et réuni la presse ce jeudi pour
dénoncer son entrée dans la campagne
pour la mairie patrick jacques de
dixmude et grégory canada à presque 32
ans il se lance dans sa deuxième
campagne des élections municipales à
trappes
en 2014 le conseiller d'opposition
othman nassr où était arrivé en deuxième
position avec 30 % des voix en
s'appuyant déjà à l'époque sur son
association trappe citoyens c'est à
trappes que j'ai démarré mon engagement
politique que j'ai pris des
responsabilités politiques importantes
depuis l agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines à la région ile de france
mais que c'est ici que ça a commencé que
sept trappistes que je le dois j'ai le
sentiment aujourd'hui avec cette
expérience que j'ai pu acquérir de
pouvoir être utile priorité absolue pour
lui attrape l'éducation et la réussite
scolaires pour bâtir son projet celui
qui est vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines et élu régional dans des
majorités de droite entend proposer pour
les municipales une liste rassemblant
diverses sensibilités politiques
à ses côtés pour annoncer sa candidature
ça mieux labo ancien membre de la
majorité du maire divers gauche de
trappes qui vient de rejoindre
l'opposition
le temps des étiquettes des appareils il
n'est pas devant nous il plutôt derrière
long par contre aujourd'hui c'est le
temps du local des idées des projets et
c'est ça que j'ai envie
de porter aussi comme je le fais depuis
2014 mais d'une manière maintenant
qu'ils soient parfaitement claires et
parfaitement audible avec le
rassemblement le plus large
d'autres candidats se sont fait
connaître attrape le maire sortant guy
malandain seront en lice pour un
quatrième mandat
mustapha larbaoui s'est lui aussi lancé
dans la campagne reste à déterminer s'il
sera tête de liste ou simple colistiers
politique économique à présent retour
sur le colloque de génération
entreprises entrepreneurs associés
organisé par l'association de
parlementaires ce jeudi 6 juin à
l'assemblée nationale
cet événement a permis d'aborder le
sujet à de la guerre économique et de la
place de la france dans ce conflit des
échanges sur la cybersécurité le
patriotisme économique
reportage de nicolas landry la guerre
économique et commerciale entre la chine
et les etats-unis les présidentes donald
trump exige in ping s'affrontent à coups
de droits de douane et de sanctions
quid de la france et de l'union
européenne dans ce conflit c'est le
thème du colloque organisé par
l'association génération entreprise
présidée par olivier dassault et jean
michel fourgous avec la question du
patriotisme économique
on a souvent assimilé le patriotisme
économique au protectionnisme c'est pas
du tout la même chose protectionnisme
c'est le repli complet sur soi c'est la
mythologie de l'autosuffisance du
patriotisme économique ce n'est jamais
que la défense et la promotion de nos
intérêts économiques qui en particulier
industrielles dans le respect du
principe de réciprocité est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs part jean michel fourgous
dans le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines participe justement de la
promotion de ce patriotisme économique
auquel je suis si attaché airbus thalès
ou encore safran plusieurs leaders
industriels installés sur saint quentin
en yvelines des géants français et
européens mais insuffisant selon bernard
carayon je crois qu'il manque encore
d'une vraie politique industrielle en
europe et cette politique industrielle
aujourd'hui est entravée par la
politique de la concurrence qui
repêchent nos grandes eaux de se
constituer en mastodonte pour affronter
justement les mastodontes américains
indiens ou chinois
autre sujet abordé la cybersécurité avec
un engagement particulier de saint
quentin en yvelines pour soutenir la
formation dans ce domaine
les formations en tout cas si la
sécurité nous on mélange est très belles
boîtes les plus belles bottes française
sur la cybersécurité sur le numérique
avec des jeunes et des moins jeunes et
des écoles qui veulent réussir donc
voilà c'est ce ce mariage subtil qui
fera la pertinence certainement de la
réussite de la france qui se protégera
dans cette révolution
la cyber sécurité un enjeu important
dans un contexte de guerre économique
d'après les prévisions le nombre de
cyberattaques devrait augmenter de 500 %
d'ici à 2020
direction paris le monde rural était en
question à la bellevilloise dans le 20e
arrondissement le but changer le regard
sur la réalité et sur ses difficultés
reportage de via campari la
bellevilloise 20e arrondissement on a
beau être en plein paris c'est bien le
monde rural qui est à l'honneur
ici on veut mettre en avant les
initiatives et les projets des
territoires ruraux à la communale est
utile et plus largement le monde rural
est utile au pays au développement du
pays
à partir de là il faut être exubérant il
faut être assis dos affirmé il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont et ne
pas laisser croire que le monde et la
france 9 ne fonctionne que parce qu'il
ya des grandes villes john billard mr2
le favril en eure et loire un village de
360 habitants
comme beaucoup de territoires ruraux sa
commune fait face à une pénurie de
médecins pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale
il veut expérimenter dans sa mairie la
télémédecine le patient rentre à
l'intérieur de la cabine s'enferme à
l'intérieur comme non
un photomaton si je puis dire et est en
lien direct avec un médecin
enter en visioconférence et il va
utiliser les instruments de
consultations médicales sur conseil du
médecin la ruralité est aussi un
laboratoire d'idées tous les jours des
innovations émergent dans les
territoires cet organisme se charge de
recenser tous les projets novateurs en
europe
la deuxième étape sera de proposer des
solutions clés en main dans les zones
isolées
c'est répertoriés et repérer les bonnes
pratiques les capitaliser et diffuser le
guide de bonnes pratiques si on veut qui
sera réalisé dans le cadre du projet ce
sera un guide méthodologique qui
présentera une méthodologie de travail
pour mettre en place des nouveaux
services ou les maintenir sur leurs
territoires
aujourd'hui un français sur deux rêvent
de quitter la ville pour la campagne
preuve que les territoires ruraux ont
toujours la cote dans le coeur des
français
un mot des intempéries qui ont touché
les yvelines à mardi dernier en alerte
orange le département a subi de violents
orages vous voyez ces images tournées
mardi soir sur la nationale 186 la
chaussée inondée de plusieurs
centimètres d'eau à hauteur du chéné
rocancourt d'autres inondations mais
aussi les dégâts de toiture et des
chutes d'arbres ont été recensés surtout
dans le nord-est lutte des territoires
les pompiers des yvelines indique avoir
reçu 175 demandes de secours des dégâts
également à l'arboretum de versailles
chèvreloup près du château de versailles
une cinquantaine d'arbres sont tombés
mardi dernier et près de 200 arbres ont
été abîmés avec des branches cassées les
équipes sont au travail depuis les
intempéries pour réparer les dégâts des
opérations qui devraient durer au moins
deux semaines ce qui entraîne la
fermeture du site on écoute son
directeur frédéric h il au micro de tv
78 on n'a pas souvent des arbres comme
ça qu'ils tombent on a eu la grande
tempête de 1999 où il ya une grande
grande partie des arbres qui sont tombés
en fin de partie
des centaines et des centaines d'arbres
mais des dégâts comme ça c'est quand
même vraiment exceptionnel on n'a pas vu
arriver le vent mais visiblement il ya
des arbres qui ont été emportés par des
vents tourbillonnant qui ont arraché des
arbres qui était en pleine santé encore
et donc c'est assez impressionnant parce
qu'on voit des arbres qui on en est
qu'elle ne s'attendait pas du tout à
avoir des dégâts des intempéries qui
n'ont pas perturbé le programme de
l'équipe de france féminine les joueuses
se sont entraînés tout au long de la
semaine dans les yvelines pour préparer
au mieux leur coupe du monde organisée
du 7 juin au 7 juillet lundi dernier les
bleus étaient à claire pour scène pour
la dernière ligne droite des jeunes de
croissy sur seine ont eu la chance de
pouvoir assister à la séance depuis à
les tribunes et encourager leurs
protégés pendant plus d'une heure en
montage de jules grenier fils ils ont
fait beaucoup de bruit plus de 400
jeunes venus principalement de croissy
sur seine se sont rendus ce lundi matin
à clairefontaine pour un entraînement de
l'équipe de france féminine a rendez
vous programmé quatre jours seulement
avant leur premier match de coupe du
monde
j'aime bien tu as envie de crier allez
les bleus c'est bien si on ne les voit
pas tous les jours
c'est les professionnels
allez les bleus c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on peut les voir c'est
passer des joueuses professionnelles
c'est ben hassine c'est magnifique table
donne envie de devenir peau de dégâts
les villes sélectionnées par la fifa
croissy-sur-seine recevra les bleus
pendant la coupe du monde pour créer
l'effervescence la commune n'a pas
hésité à affréter plusieurs bus pour
emmener les jeunes à la session d'avoir
la joie d'avoir des enfants heureux
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a accueilli
l'équipe de france c'est pour
transmettre ses valeurs de ce sport et
d'amour et de joie comment on trouve ici
dans un stade
après les tribunes direction les
terrains la matinée s'est terminée par
une séance de dédicaces avec les
joueuses tous ont voulu un souvenir de
cette journée de la compétition approche
plus plus agrandi pour iliad
effervescents son club c'est bien pour
nous c'est positif
les enfants ils sont pleins d'énergie
donc on en prend c'est bien ça fait
plaisir
en plus il ya beaucoup d'enfants et
c'est vrai qu'à notre âge
en bas on rêvait quoi de ça une belle
surprise ce matin ses regrets après
avoir rencontré les jeunes de croissy
sur seine les bleus fouleront pour la
première fois la pelouse du stade
omnisports de la ville ce jeudi six
joueurs pour un entraînement à huis clos
avant leur premier match contre la corée
du sud après clairefontaine et féminines
de l'équipe de france se sont entraînés
ce jeudi à 3 juin huit clos à
croissy-sur-seine comme on peut le voir
sur ces images
objectif préparer leur premier match de
la compétition contre la corée du sud ne
rencontre programmée ce vendredi soir au
parc des princes le terrain de croissy
sur seine recevra également pendant la
compétition l'afrique du sud et à
l'ecosse football toujours mais cette
fois ci à masculin championnat trophée
des champions coupe de france coupe de
la ligue et coupe d'europe avec le psg
laurent fournier a tout gagné ou presque
autant dire que son arrivée au club de
poissy au poste d'entraîneur permet de
nourrir de sérieux espoirs pour la
saison prochaine un reportage de wilfrid
richy formé à l'olympique lyonnais où il
disputera deux cent soixante matchs dans
les années 80 passé par saint-etienne
marseille et paris laurent fournier 54
ans est aujourd'hui le nouvel entraîneur
de l'as poissy conférence de presse ce
jeudi matin pour le nouvel homme fort du
football pisciacais c'est toujours
valorisant d'être sur un terrain
de faire partager ce qui nous a permis
de gagner pas mal de titres de faire
comprendre aux jeunes que
de travailler à l'extérieur c'est
toujours mieux que de travailler à
l'intérieur et que le sport et ben c'est
le foot c'est populaire c'est ça permet
d'aller de s'extérioriser d'être bien
dans sa peau son ambition la montée
d'ici deux ans la haye ce poids si
actuellement national de la 4e division
française et qui vient de terminer cette
saison à la 9e place
je pense que on a effectivement d'un
côté la difficulté d'être du monde
amateur mais c'est un monde formidable
et d'un autre côté des anciens pros qui
sont fédéraux donc c'est de retrouver
alchimie entre ces jeunes donc ces
jeunes issus de la fois ci de les faire
monter en nationale 2 et ses anciens de
les entourer
je pense que c'est très important
aujourd'hui pour réussir notre projet le
psg est le red star créteil laurent
fournier retrouve donc une place sur le
banc d'une équipe francilienne puis de
trois ans après avoir quitté son dernier
poste d'entraîneur il reprend du service
et ne devrait pas déroger à sa
réputation d' homme combatif et
possédant un certain franc-parler
j'ai pas trouvé que c'était incohérent
cette année j'ai juste trouvé qu'il y
avait les résultats étaient en dents de
scie donc peut-être problème
de mental mais on l'a vu le mental n'y a
pas que l' exploit s'il ya certaines
équipes comme le paris saint germain qui
ont perdu contre manchester alors qu'ils
avaient mené 2 0 et là aussi c'est pas
un problème de qualité
c'est juste un problème de d'exigence et
quand on est exigeant je crois qu'on
arrive à faire pas mal de choses
on continue à parler de sport un rendez
vous qu'il ne faudra absolument pas
manquer ce week-end dans les villes la
coupe du monde de bmx l'eau rendez vous
est programmé ce samedi 8 et dimanche 9
juin les meilleurs pilotes de la planète
vont s'affronter à côté du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines au
total 250 sportifs et 25 pays seront
représentés dont la france qui comptera
neuf pilotes nous nous sommes rendus sur
une journée d'entraînement une manche de
coupe du monde sera organisée ici ce
week-end au stadium de bmx 2 saint
quentin en yvelines à mes côtés deux
acteurs qui vont participer à cette
manche de coupe du monde julien sastre
le sélectionneur et romain mahieu qui
sera compétiteurs sur l'événement tu un
astre comment se passent ces derniers
jours ça se passe bien donc plus
sérieusement un peu comme chaque semaine
de coupe du monde que l'on rencontre
c'est à dire on essaie d'être assez
relaxe en début de semaine puis petit à
petit voilà les pilotes se mettent dans
la course monte en puissance au fur et à
mesure de la semaine pour arriver voilà
au maximum de concentration sur le
week-end samedi et dimanche
pas trop de stress romain non ça va en
plus vu que vu que c'est la maison le
stress et est moindre que quand on va
rouler à l'extérieur et tout va bien le
groupe viennent tous de se regrouper et
là en début de semaine
et l'ambiance est bonne comme d'habitude
du coup on est tous tous excités de
rouler ce week end justement vous êtes
le local vous disiez à l'instant de
l'étape est ce qu a pas plus de pression
ou 19 noms mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas
plus de pression plus de monde tiendra
vous voir non je en tout cas pour ma
part non l'année année dernière j avais
pas eu je sentais pas plus de pression
même si j'étais à domicile c'est limite
si c'est plus un boost c'est ça rend les
choses plus faciles d'avoir le public
derrière nous d'être heureux d'être chez
nous donc maintenant j'espère encore
revoir beaucoup de gens cette année
beaucoup de gens du duc ou à venir nous
encourager
alors l'année dernière vous aviez fait
deuxième parce que cette année vous
allez faire la même chose
j'espère et j'espère même pourquoi pas
faire mieux donc l'année dernière
j'étais j'étais passé pas très loin de
de pouvoir gagner une des 2 donc
donc voilà cette année les objectifs ça
sera d'aller en chercher à chercher une
victoire
je viens ce qu'il a le potentiel pour
remporter une victoire aujourd'hui tout
à fait il l'a déjà prouvé sur d'autres
manches de coupe du monde notamment
comme romain viens de dire sur sur la
manche de l'an dernier et puis pour ce
qui est de l'ensemble du groupe
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure avec
avec lui je pense que l'ensemble du
groupe a surtout envie c'est pas
tellement de la pression ça nous procure
de l'envi l'année dernière le public
était venu nombreux nous avait supporté
nous avait porté nous a donné beaucoup
de force
donc du coup et c'est surtout leur envie
qu'on ressent quand on sait que le
groupe dans son ensemble ressent
comment vous avez fait pour sélectionner
ce groupe est bien celle des sélections
qui ont lieu au fur et à mesure des
manches de coupe du monde qui seront qui
ont lieu sur soi les saisons précédentes
soit la saison en cours mais globalement
le groupe qui est là ce week end c'est
un groupe qui est habitué de l'équipe de
france c'est un peu le groupe cadre
les neuf pilotes là qui vont rouler donc
trois filles et 6 garçons avec des
pilotes issus voilà les fers de lance
issus de ce qu'on appelle nous notre
programme olympique et d'autres pilotes
issus un peu plus jeune de la jeune
génération qui constituent le programme
relève
vous visez combien de médailles c'est
toujours dur de conté avant l'heure
l'équipe de france a fait un excellent
début de saison cette année avec
notamment un triplé première une
première place de joris daudet deuxième
de jérémy rencurel troisième de sylvain
andré sur la première manche sur
l'ouverture de cette saison coupe du
monde à manchester
je vous avoue que chez les garçons on
espère faire aussi bien et les puits
sont pas en reste puisque manon
valentino a elle gagné la deuxième
manche de coupe du monde à manchester
également donc du coup voilà aujourd'hui
je pense que à la maison l'équipe de
france fait figure de favori donc un
nombre exact de podium je pourrais pas
trop m'avancer pour vous dire mais en
tout cas le maximum qu'on pourra aider
victoire est ce qu'on peut dire qu'on
est un peu dans une génération dorée
je pense oui ça fait ça fait deux trois
ans come back on le montre sur chaque
sur chaque gros événement sur les coupes
du monde et les championnats de roche
mère du monde donc
donc pour l'instant et la dynamique est
bonne sur chaque course compétition on
est au rendez vous et on va faire en
sorte que ça continue qu'est ce qui fait
la force de cette équipe de france
le fait qu'elle soit sérieuse mais en
même temps décontractée c'est un peu la
marque de fabrique effectivement de
l'équipe c'est à dire que le groupe est
capable à la fois d'être très rigoureux
très engagé quand quand voilà quand il
ya le job à faire et en même temps très
relax dans les moments où on peut être
relax et je pense qu'une vraie force
mine de rien même dans une discipline
individuelle de cette équipe c'est
vraiment le groupe et l'état d'esprit
qui règne dans ce groupe et une bonne
ambiance tout le monde se tire vers le
haut les pilotes ne se juge pas entre
eux centraide et je crois que c'est
vraiment un très gros plus on va parler
de cette piste que vous connaissez par
coeur romain mahieu quelles sont ses
difficultés c'est qu'elle est très
technique par rapport aux plus qu'on a
maintenant sur les sur le circuit du
coup il faut rester vraiment concentré
tout le monde la piste on n'a pas trop
le temps de ceux de pouvoir se relâchent
et de se détendre de passants attention
donc ça va sûrement rsa va être de
rester concentré jusqu'au bout pas faire
d'erreurs techniques pour pourquoi
partir leur foi il ya aussi un paramètre
qu'il faudra prendre en compte forcément
c'est l'aspect climatique il ya beaucoup
de vent aujourd'hui on ne sait pas s'il
y en aura également ce week-end en quoi
s'ajoute le vent sur les performances
c'est plutôt sur sur les sauts en fête
du conte comme on passe beaucoup de
temps en l'air il ya des moments s'il ya
du vent qui vient de côté ça peut nous
gêner c'est vraiment le seul problème
après quand ça aix et c'est pas c'est
pas très gênant et du bon sens tradition
de tous les jours on a l'habitude du
vent après faut voir quelle quelle force
devant aussi mais ce sera vraiment ça
s'il ya vraiment du vent le problème
après je pense que c'est lui qu'on roule
un peu en soirée ça devrait peut-être se
calmer et ça ça va nous offrir quand
même deux belles courses et de bonnes
conditions
il ya également un paramètre qui ferait
à prendre en compte c'est la chance
forcément c'est un sport où il faut
quand même un peu de chance on alors moi
je parlerais plutôt de réussite parce
qu'effectivement oui il peut y avoir en
bmx des situations avec avec des chutes
ça arrive fréquemment ça fait partie de
la discipline mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi savoir provoquer la chance et se
mettre dans les conditions pour pouvoir
provoquer la chance donc c'est ce qui
nous a souri c'était cet élément là nous
a souri jusqu'ici il n'y a pas de raison
que ça fasse pas aussi ce week-end on
attend environ 12000 personnes sur cet
événement est ce que vous comptez sur
l'appui du public
évidemment évidemment l'année dernière
il s'était beaucoup étaient présents
pour nous supporter
on les a entendus et nous ont aidés ils
ont poussé du coup on compte bien on
compte bien en voir autant cette année
un dernier mot pour eux ben déjà merci
pour ceux qui vont venir qui ont prévu
de venir et puis venez nombreux nous
donner de la force nous encourager et
-surtout- les encourager parce que l'an
dernier ça a été ouais on parle on parle
de douzième homme dans un sport comme le
foot bal à nous ça a été un pilote de
plus dans l'équipe et quels pilotes
parce que ça nous a énormément de force
il va y avoir du spectacle
d'ailleurs du grand spectacle du grand
grand spectacle monde donc j'espère
j'espère vous voir nombreux
merci beaucoup à tous les deux et bon
courage pour cette manche de coupe du
monde qui je le rappelle sont organisées
à ce week-end sur le stadium de bmx de
saint quentin en yvelines après le bmx
un mot de baseball l'équipe des cougars
de monti le bretonneux joue cette
semaine la coupe d'europe à brno en
république tchèque les il monte un
réussi à battre l'équipe des astres
hausse de valencia le score 6 1 pour les
saint quentinois une première victoire
européenne dans l'histoire du club la
compétition se termine dimanche 9 juin
on passe maintenant à notre page résumé
la semaine
[Musique]
les passionnés de cheval ont rendez vous
du 2 au 4 août au prochain au haras des
bréviaires à l'édition 2019 de l'est qui
rendent au a été présenté ce jeudi c'est
la première fois que cette manifestation
phare du tourisme équestre français se
déroule dans les yvelines reportage
d'aurélie rose et d'oceana bazire
propriété du département des yvelines le
haras des bréviaires accueillera dans
moins de deux mois le plus gros
rassemblement européen de tourisme
équestre
près de mille cavaliers sont attendus
sur ce site de 55 hectares pour la 52e
édition de l'est qui rendent au le
maître mot c'est de partir d'où l'on
veut quand on veut avec un principe de
liberté à travers l'itinérance à cheval
à cheval ou en attelage donc les et qui
rendent un par des quatre coins de
france et des quatre coins d'europe
voire même de plus loin on a vu du raid
et des cavaliers japonais chinois russes
pour rejoindre un point de ralliement
avec trois jours de fête et convivialité
à partager avec les autres et qui
randonnent pour participer à l'est qui
rende il faut avoir parcouru au moins
100 km au fil des ans cette
manifestation annuelle a permis de
structurer le tourisme équestre une
activité fortement implanté en île de
france
près de cent mille cavaliers licenciés
en ile de france pour pratiquer
l'équitation mais ont pu multiplier par
le chiffre par cinq si on compte tous
les pratiquants tous ceux qui sont
amoureux du cheval et qui à un moment ou
un autre monte à poney ou à cheval
c'est la première fois que les qui
rendent au fait étape dans les yvelines
l'occasion pour les participants de
découvrir un peu mieux le patrimoine et
le terroir yvelinois la vision
internationale que va être les qui
rendent au va nous permettre
effectivement de mettre en avant notre
territoire les yvelines et va mettre en
avant cela partir ruralité j'insiste
vraiment sur cette identité rurale qui
est très forte au niveau du département
du 2 au 4 août le public pourra
également assister gratuitement au
spectacle et aux démonstrations
d'équitation qui auront lieu au haras
des bréviaires des conférences sans
association 80 concerts 1 900 solide est
ce bien la fin du mois de juin à paris
longchamp un festival organisé en
partenariat avec la région ile de france
depuis sa création plus de 3 millions de
spectateurs en fouler les pelouses de
l'hippodrome
reportage de mélanie poké et audrey h
ailleurs 37 millions de personnes vivent
avec le vih dans le monde
et même si l'accès aux traitements
évoluer progresse il ya encore 40 % des
malades dans le monde qui n'ont pas
accès aux traitements
solidays c'est dans moins de trois
semaines le festival en faveur de la
lutte contre le sida revient pour une
21e édition
c'est aussi un rendez-vous qu'on attend
tous parce que ça c'est un week-end qui
fait du bien c'est un week-end intérêts
publics c'est un week-end où on se sent
plus proche des autres où il ya de la
bienveillance de l'empathie ça me permet
d'assister à des colloques de rencontrer
des gens ou ensuite d'acheter des
bouquins intéressant qui nous permette
de grandir de m'éduquer et puis ensuite
de repasser à la musique il ya tout qui
est condensée dans ce festival cette
année encore l'ile-de-france et
partenaires un soutien à hauteur de 800
mille euros la région est
particulièrement touché chaque jour 7
franciliens découvrent leur
séropositivité
nous avons un grand festival de musique
populaire française et ça est
indépendant et ça c'est très important
culturellement c'est très important
c'est un festival qui est un supplément
d'âme un supplément d'âme parce que la
question de la lutte contre le sida est
majeur tu l'as dit pour l'ile-de-france
80 concerts répartis sur 3 jours le
festival attire chaque année des
nouveaux artistes mais aussi des fidèles
hocus pocus se reforme pour une tournée
anniversaire celui d'oeil c'est un des
plus beaux festivals qu'on ait fait on a
vraiment des souvenirs particuliers où
on s'est retrouvé à jouer dans quarante
cinquante mille personnes
on nous a souvent programmés sur des
débuts de projets aussi quand s'était
pas lancé par exemple sur alta où
c'était incroyable sous le chapiteau en
ce moment on est à fond sur l'engagement
c'est un truc qui est qu'on a compris
c'est un truc qui est venu avec le
succès qu'on a compris en se disant on a
un gros audimat il ya des grands enjeux
en ce moment dans notre époque actuelle
donc il vous qu'on fasse partie de ça
pour être solidaire c'est du 21 au 23
juin à paris longchamp l'an dernier le
festival avait battu un record de
fréquentation plus de 212 mille
spectateurs s'étaient déplacés
les départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine une nouvelle fois a réuni
ce mardi 4 juin pour la première fête
inter départementale du numérique
objectif mettre en avant les dispositifs
éducatifs innovants qui existe au sein
des collèges ont fait le point avec
aurélie ronces des jeunes mieux formés
grâce à la révolution numérique c'est ce
qu'on souhaitait montrer les
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine lors de cette première
fête du numérique il faut que à tous les
endroits des territoires départementaux
chaque élève a et la même chance de
réussir et l'espace numérique
c'est un outil formidable pour justement
aboutir à cette égalité des chances
par exemple à l'égard des décrocheurs on
arrive à repérer leurs carences et de
leur construire une orientation qui va
leur permettre de combler les trous
qu'ils peuvent avoir plusieurs projets
pédagogiques ont fait l'objet de
conférences et de partage d'expériences
concours robotique
ou encore exposition de maquettes sur le
collège de demain l'occasion également
de présenter un nouvel établissement qui
ouvrira ses portes en 2021 à mantes la
jolie et dans lequel le numérique aura
toute sa place
qu'est ce qu'un collège de demain
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait besoin pour
étudier le mieux possible et en fonction
de ça on a adapté tous les locaux aux
besoins des usagers
ce rendez vous d'aujourd'hui il illustre
finalement l'investissement de chacun y
met celui des collectivités locales
celui de l'état mais il illustre aussi
la réponse qu'on espère vivent aux
besoins de nos enseignants et de nous de
nos élèves
au cours de cette journée le département
des yvelines et le rectorat ont
également signé trois conventions en
faveur de l'inclusion
elle prévoit notamment le prêt d'outils
numériques pour les collégiens en
situation de handicap
c'est la fin de cette émission très bon
week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
e